hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the mystifying analytical
validation while onboarding NGS test i
am michelle ashton of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speakers Jeffrey
bien Senior Product Manager at Thermo
Fisher Scientific and Lea Ames
coordinator of the molecular biology
department at Alverno Laboratories for a
complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen our speakers will now
begin their presentations
Thank You Michelle and thank you
everybody for joining us today my name
is Jeffrey BIA and I'm a project manager
at Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm in our
analytical validation consulting
services group and let's go ahead and
get started
this is the agenda of my talk today
we're going to start with a very
high-level overview of the cap
guidelines as well as other guidelines
are out there for analytical validation
my goal today is not to go in depth
about guidelines there's a very
fantastic webinar that was given by cap
on October 17 I highly suggest that if
you haven't had the chance to take a
look then go back take a listen to it
they really break down on what they
require for labs win validating next-gen
sequencing oncology assays we're then
going to segue into the cement purchase
process what happens when you buy an
instrument from thermo Fisher Scientific
and you know how does that look from
instrument purchase all the way through
your analytic validation will then go
over preparing for analytical validation
and what we suggest the customers steps
that you should take really to get
yourself ready to you know undertake all
the runs that come with doing it and a
local validation will then review common
customer struggles I don't know if some
people out there are in the middle of
validating there's some struggles that
you're experiencing but we'll go over
what we found being in the field working
with customers and what we you know have
have heard from customers you know going
into creating the service as well we'll
then go over a very high-level
analytical validation plan example and
we'll finish up by giving an overview of
the analytical validation consultant
services that are offered by a central
official scientific
I really like these next two slides in
the presentation today I think that
they're great at distilling down
essential information and clarifying
common misconceptions that people might
have this slide right here shows a
comparison of the major operational
standards for clinical testing
laboratory now you might ask yourself
what is an operational standards well
essentially it is the quality management
system guidance to the industry so if we
look what we have right here we have
CLIA cap ISO 15 189 and chce LSI if you
want individual direct requirements
we've added the citations below and the
gray boxes down there
this next slide gives the technical
acetate validation guidelines by agency
you can see that we have a new player in
here of the New York State Department of
Health but what I like to do when going
over this and talking to groups about
this as I like to really highlight the
commonalities that we see between the
different regulatory agencies on where
you need to hit you know especially for
an analytical validation you can see you
know if you look at CLIA cap New York
State Department of Health MCA clsi
although some have you know a few more
categories than the other ones they
really hit down on you know covering
your accuracy if your analytical
sensitivity your precision and
reproducibility and your analytical
specificity these ones will get a little
bit more of an overview and what we
recommend going through a high-level
validation plan but I encourage groups
to always get to indirect requirements
and the explanation of what they want to
see for each of the categories in these
so what happens after instrument is
purchased from thermo Fisher Scientific
typically what happens is the customer
will either pick their instrument that
they want to run or they pick their
assay typically what we see customers do
is they're interested in what running
one of our assays so they'll come to our
technical sales team and they'll say I'm
interested in purchasing the alkaline
myeloid outside automatic focus assay
and the technical sales team will work
with them and help build in a sort of an
instrument setup around that you know if
there's any future plans to run one of
our Marc high-throughput assays we'll
make sure that you have the correct
instrumentation in place that will be
able to handle that you know in for any
future plans that you have then the
assay that you want to initially launch
lift so what happens is you'll you'll
purchase your instrument and of course
your instrument will need to be
installed so the local field the field
local field engine engineer will come
on-site he'll install your instrument
he'll give a brief overview training of
how to use the instrument but then we'll
go into more in-depth training that's
when your local field application
scientist will come in and train on the
amplifi core flow and give you more
in-depth instrument training as well and
then you'll be trained by your local
application consulting that will do
training itself on the a say that you
are deciding to run so whether it be I
know gave the example of Don Klein focus
on combined myeloid acid but let's say
you get run with by Lloyd they'll give
you an exact reading on the myeloid
assay you'll also receive another
training from a field bioinformatics
specialist that will go more in depth on
how to use the software will you know
whether it be torn sweet iron reporter
and then if you decide to go with our
online reporter to solution will train
you on that as well after that of course
you'll need to move into your analytical
validation in your clinical validation
and then once you complete that step you
can go to actually implementation if you
decide to move forward with thermal
fissures AV service we like to get
involved at the beginning so at
instrument purchase and you'll see in a
couple slides I'll highlight why we like
to do that but will be involved with you
through the whole process
preparing for any local
Foundation
that we really you know tell customers
they need to ask themselves before you
know going into validation whether or
not you're using our thermo Fisher Navy
service you know question number one why
I think is the most important how
stringent will my analytical validation
be are you going to validate towards New
York State Department of Health
standards or is that something that
you're not concerned about
you know that what kind of plays off
side question is how many samples I want
to run for each each study do I want to
stick with a minimum recommendation or
no mainly for my accuracy portion of the
studying or where I'm running intended
sample type or do I want to supplement
that portion of the study with a lot
more with a lot more samples that are
going to have more variance that I can
cover
and what type of sample should I use now
are you going to validate towards just
running on on lung or you're going to
have the pan-cancer after we want to
pull in different mixed tumor types and
then also you know depending on your ask
there you doing myeloid are you doing
solid tumor you know to just run FFPE or
you need to run also peripheral blood
and bone marrow because you always need
to validate towards the type of sample
they're going to see when you're running
operationally
there are those samples characterized
and you have an orthogonal data set to
go along with that characterization
no one needs to be sequence for each
study you know what exactly do you need
to do for your reproducibility your
precision and and your analytical
sensitivity then how do you highlight
those metrics and more importantly how
do you sum up those metrics in your
validation report you know how do you
make a report at the end of the day when
the auditor is looking at it they can
see the direct evidence that you
fulfilled all your analytical validation
requirements
I think another question that is
commonly overlooked is to have an sob
from why that's so P paper my apologies
do you have an sob from library prep to
varying call me and this is really
important I always use this analogy you
does your SOT not only tell the baker
how to bake the cake but does it give
the Baker the importance of baking the
cake which is something that's really
important I think a lot of people forget
and that's compete that when I'm reading
an SOP I like to see this is the
importance of why I'm running my assay
not just here's a stepwise direction on
how to do it
these are common customer struggles that
we've seen working with customers out in
the coelom the first one project
management we've had customers that have
literally told us they have 10% of their
time to oversee validation so I think
it's easy to forget sometimes that you
know there's still clinical operation
that's having to go on in the background
and I think Leo will take this up in her
presentation is that there's still
clinical duties that need to be done
while you're trying to validate and so a
lot of that's project management and
then samples and controls do you have
samples in the house all ready to run
for your validation you know do you know
what controls you want to include for
each study data analysis during the
course of an analytical validation we
can be looking up words depending on
multiplexing now say you're running
there would be a little clean up any
words of you know 20-plus runs in these
labs that we work with they're very new
they're very new to next-gen sequencing
they're very new connection data
analysis and you know do they have the
capacity to be able to do 20 runs worth
of data analysis and you know the four
to six weeks that we're looking at you
know getting those runs done and then
documentation again as I mentioned you
know with SOP in a previous slide but
also with your report you know do you
have compliance documentation you have
the documentation that is going to lay
out you know your validation report on
showing that you cover in all the
aspects you needed to and then your SOP
so this is a very high-level overview of
validation plan example we start with
analytical accuracy this is where you're
running your well characterized samples
you know so that could be your cordial
hapmap samples your genome in a bottle
what you're really doing is assessing
the error rate of your sequencing and
that's because these samples of in
sequence thousands of time and their
data is publicly available for you to
download for you to do that comparison
you know from your data that you
generated we then segue into do it in
the analytical sensitivity that's
assessing your limit of detection of
course you want to do that follow
variant types and you also we want to do
limited input study so with limited
detection typically we use cell lines we
dilute them and background the vo normal
DNA RNA to target allele frequency copy
number or or fusion reads just depending
on excuse me just impending on you know
what your assays designed to detect you
can also use pool tribe controls as well
I know New York State does not recommend
using contrived controls but if you're
not you know concerned about doing a
little cool validation towards New York
state standards you can use these
controls are available and they're pre
diluted towards target you know target
allele frequency copy number refused to
recount
he then you know want to do limited
input study what that limit is input
study does is saying you know if I take
my recommended 10 20 nanograms total
input and I you know drop it down to one
nanogram total input with hitting a few
points in between my key am I able to
detect the same variant calls at my
lower inputs and then I detect at my you
know normal recommended inputs we then
segue into doing accuracy this is where
you're really running the meat of it
you're really running your intended
sample type we also use contrived
controls and cell lines mainly to build
up the number of variants you know
fusion events are very rare and samples
that are out there and so typically what
we'll do is we'll take a concoction
drive control and we'll run that and
they'll build up the number of fusions
that we have that we look at that are
assays designed to detect
we then do precision this is our intro
assay repeatability you know if we take
that one sample repeated in triplicate
and on the same same system by the same
operator on the same day are we able to
get you know the same very result we
want to make sure we include all
variants covered by that F covered by
the asset as well
we will then finish up with
reproducibility this is our you know
interacts a reproducibility if I take a
handful samples and I run them you know
on different systems by different
operators different days different
barcodes am I able to get the same
results you know across all those
replicates as well and again just like
precision we're going to make sure that
we include all varying types covered by
the assets
analytical validation consulting
services for next-gen sequencing assays
so what is it I always like to start on
this one by reading the source intro
paragraph here
I mean areas Castle tinkin services
consulting services provides technical
project management of your labs AV to
help verify advanced A's tested for
required required parameters to work
with you to optimize and develop your
validation workflow while providing data
analysis support and template
documentation as part of your end in and
this termination investment so in a
really high-level sense you know we are
technical project managers our goal is
to do everything we can without actually
physically picking up a pipette in the
lab to make going through the AV process
as easy and streamlined as possible for
customers you can see we support a wide
variety of our next-gen sequencing
oncology assays all the way from our
OnCommand branded assays to you know we
we offer ad services for inherited
cancer research panel then we also do
custom acids as well
and the goal really of this is to help
accelerate your launch time and then
help reduce costs and add transparencies
your Emma investment and then we all
wall beat under this a compliant
umbrella
this is a overview of the timeline and
what it looks like if we start at the
very left there the first two weeks in
three weeks these are things I would go
on you know whether you're under Rab
consulting services or not your first
two weeks you pick out your ass that you
get your instrumentation you'll have
personnel assigned to you then if we go
into the next three weeks that's where
you're going to get your instrument
installed and get trained by your
appropriate personnel and then that week
that one week after that those three
weeks is where we really pick up the ad
services this is where we'll go over
target of sequencing metrics what we
want to hit they're an analytical
validation will go over samples and
controls what we're going to do for each
study will really make sure that we have
and hyoeun doubt analytical validation
plan but again as I always say we like
to stretch that one week out into those
first five weeks just so the more time
we have to talk about the process the
better it will be for what we see is
those six weeks after that one week
those six weeks right there is the lab
is going to be pumping through running
running through the studies and running
samples and we're going to try to maps
out the sequencers capability just so we
can you know crunch down the sequencing
but get it all done you know within a
short time frame while that's going
while those six weeks are going on we're
going to be hopping on weekly calls with
the analytical validation project
manager will be going over data in
real-time so the lab will be sending us
data for us to analyse we'll go over
that data in real time on the meeting
and talk about the next few runs for you
know the week prior for the week coming
up my apologies for the week coming up
and then after that it takes about one
to two weeks to compile the rest of the
data and you know polish it up and then
a week after that to you know get a
finalized analytical validation report
there's certain things that we cannot do
is thermo Fisher Scientific we can't
help with accreditation we can't help
with clinical reporting and so you know
those are areas that is the labs
responsibility after our AV service
mr. AV consulting service you know what
do we provide and what you receive of
course we provide the project management
during the course of the analytical
validation we'll also work closely with
our look with your local clinical
application consulting that will train
you on the assay and we like to make
sure that you as a lab feel it as
comfortable as possible going into the
analytical dollar valuation and also
while you're running through they had a
local foundation itself that's because
we're doing so many runs in such a short
period of time the lab really needs to
be at a level to where they are
comfortable doing that we also provide
workflow training not an optimization if
you're using one of our extraction
systems that can go all the way from
extraction you know through sequencing
and then at the end of the analytical
validation we'll do technical review
with guidance around frequency metrics
so we'll go over all the validation runs
we'll go over the data and do a more
in-depth technical review we also have a
clinical laboratory located in
Sacramento California thermo Fisher
clinical laboratory services I believe
it's called and they do offer
confirmatory orthogonal testing that is
something that allowed needs so I
receive you know beginning you'll
receive your validation plan
you'll then also receive your SOP
templates for running the assay if
you're going with one of our solid tumor
assay we are able to provide all samples
and controls for those assay so that
would be an online focus assay or not my
comprehensive assays then during the
course of the validation we're providing
you know weekly data analysis
consultation really you know to helping
to take that burden of doing data
analysis off the web and then at the end
we'll provide a finalized analytical
validation report template if you do
decide to use our clinical laboratory of
orthogonal testing that is something
that we'll do data analysis consultation
on as well for for those results
you know at the end of the day it's all
about time costs and compliance our goal
as AV project managers is to get you
through the validation you know isn't
quickly and streamlined as possible
although all the while you're not
spending so much time on validation so
you're going to come out and be able to
get reimbursement sooner and again I
thought I mentioned it before but this
is we're doing this all under a
compliant umbrella making sure that
we're checking off those checkboxes that
are required by CLIA cap or you know or
New York State
that's what I have for you today I want
to leave you with these references I
definitely recommend with these
references go read the Jenny's paper
that's out there review your cap
checklist take a listen to the webinar
that if you haven't already that was on
October 17th that cap gave on you know
direct with my guidelines for validating
that sequence here in ecology essay take
a look at the New York State Department
of Health requirements you know review
the the clsi requirements as well and
then you know you can take a look at
your ISO 5189
recommendations on fertility in the
quality management system
so thank you all for be with it for
being with me today we're going to segue
now into Lia Ames where she is going to
give her presentation on onboarding next
gen sequencing test
great thank you Jeff and I'd like to
also thank Michelle from lab roots and
Cindy from thermo Fisher for inviting me
to speak today my name is Leah Ames I am
one of the molecular coordinators at
Alverno Laboratories I work in the
molecular biology department and I was
the project lead and laboratory
scientist responsible for implementing
next-generation sequencing at our
laboratory today I will be speaking to
you about our implementation of next
generation sequencing talking about the
challenges that we encountered and the
services that thermal Fisher provided to
us with the purchase of their analytical
validation package
as Jeff mentioned you know every
laboratory is going to have some
struggles and some challenges when they
bring in any type of new testing I'm
sure to anyone in the clinical
laboratory arena many of these bullet
points are going to look very very
familiar and with NGS there's certainly
no exceptions here our first undertaking
was where are we going to put it yeah
that's a big concern for anybody in the
laboratory obviously with sequencing
you're certainly worried about
contamination most in order to ensure
he's got good laboratory practices and
isolating an area that you know and is
designated as between so we had to put
some time into where are we going to
move current instrumentation and how are
we going to place the new
instrumentation that was coming in in
order to do that we also needed to
consider the equipment that was needed
there's obviously several different
choices when it comes to sequencing
technology PCR based or capture based
that's going to certainly make a
difference on what we decided to bring
in and how it was going to fit into the
space that we had additionally personnel
needs what was going to be the hands-on
time that we were looking at would we
consider a manual method where we going
to do completely an automated method and
in looking at those options you know
what type of staffing were we going to
have to add in order to accomplish the
turnaround time that we would provide to
our practitioners obviously quality
control is super important to laboratory
to give our patients the best data that
they can for their diagnosis but again
sequencing is a brand new arena so if
there was some confusion and certainly
some new perspectives that had to be
taken when considering quality control
because of all of the metrics involved
with the bioinformatics process which
I'll talk a little bit later on and
obviously in choosing our technology we
had to understand it
what was going to be our best fit in
terms of what we could provide you know
for turnaround time
and personnel needs and obviously every
laboratory wants to keep their cost as
minimal as possible but provide the best
diagnostic data for our clientele and as
just mentioned we certainly cannot
forget regulatory requirements there's a
lot of overseeing bodies CLIA cap we are
an ISO 15 189 laboratory so it's
important to make sure that we are
adhering to all of those criteria so
there was a lot of time spent
investigating you know all of these
organizations to see what they had to
say with regards to requirements for
next-generation sequencing testing even
clinical and laboratory standards
Institute which I believe Jeff mentioned
earlier clsi has their documentation
regarding sequencing you know dated
starting back in February of 2014 they
have nucleic acid sequencing methods
they have another one coming out that's
not even published yet that has to deal
with bioinformatics and I think that's
scheduled to be released in 2022 so I'm
sure that will add a little bit more
regulatory that will have to meet when
that documentation comes out
bioinformatics understanding obviously
there's a lot of metrics involved
there's a lot of data and there's a lot
of numbers that we're looking at in
order to determine if the results that
we're getting are true and valid and
reportable so we have to make sure that
we are understanding there so some
research went into that before during
and after the analytical validation
process and it's still ongoing
availability and sourcing of validation
samples I can't stress this one enough
as being a major obstacle for
laboratories and not just for sequencing
for any testing you know in order to
bring in a new test you have to have
valid characterized samples that have
been you know tested elsewhere and shown
to be true and real before you can go in
testing on these new instruments that
you've just brought in-house so
sourcing samples certainly was a big
struggle and you know thermal Fisher's a
B package certainly aided us in this and
again I'll be talking a little bit more
in depth about that later and also as
Jeff mentioned orthogonal testing you
know how are we going to confirm things
that may look suspicious or may not be
meeting those quality indicators that
we're looking for in terms of you know
what we performed in the validation so
these are definitely all challenges that
we faced and had to put a lot of
research into and certainly the a/b
package was able to assist us in you
know researching all of this out at the
time that we were making our choices for
instruments and validation packages
thermo Fisher had two options available
to us
option a included validation samples
it included controls and included
consulting services option B only
included consulting services only and
both options provided discounted free
agent in supply costs during the
validation period we chose to go with
option A and that was because of the
newness of the technology and the
overall experience and as I mentioned
knowing ahead of time that samples are
very difficult to come by we felt that
this was the best package for us and
moving forward with the implementation
of next-generation sequencing and as a
little bit of foreshadowing we have
purchased a second AV package through
thermal Fisher and right now we are
participating in their myeloid sa AV
package so obviously I think that hints
to the fact that our experiences went
well and we have continued our
partnership with them
so in discussing some benefits of the AV
consulting services I certainly would
say that I served as the project
management lead on this corresponding
with Jeff on a weekly basis making sure
that we had all Regent's implies that we
needed and making sure that the data
from the runs that we did got back to
him
the pre installation checklist were
totally beneficial I'm type a super
organized and I love my checklist it was
very refreshing to be wandering into
foreign territory but to have a map to
guide us through you know step by step
what needed to be done
the pre-installed checklist provided us
with a list of rage and supplies that we
needed and it also gave us description
of general lab equipment that we needed
that was not provided as part of the AV
package they also gave us instructions
on setting up a cloud through different
thermal Fisher web site because we had
to be able to transfer data
unfortunately a lot of the data files
would not go through email easily and
that was just because of either the size
or the you know weird extension that has
to do with the software that's on the
instrumentation so at least this way we
were able to transfer its MIT
information back and forth between our
organization and thermal Fisher very
very easily the IT checklist was super
important again anyone working in
clinical laboratory knows that IT
infrastructure and HIPAA compliance and
risk assessments and antivirus software
are really really important and they
certainly serve as obstacles more in the
aspect of time because that's kind of
out of the wheelhouse of the laboratory
you know we have to rely on our IT
people to work hand in hand with us we
have to get information from our vendors
and thermo Fisher included to get
talking and have conversations about
what is the software that we are putting
on these computers what type of
information
is going to be transferred over the
network is there cloud data that's going
to be occurring is there potential for
the vendor to remote access in in case
we have problems so that is all you know
really crucial in a time line for a
laboratory and thankfully the AV package
provided you know a lot of the necessary
information but furthermore we were
given contact names and numbers and
emails of people that we could
correspond with a thermo Fisher to help
us get the answers that our key our
excuse me there our IT people needed in
order to approve you know this
information going on to our our Internet
and of course last but certainly not
least on this slide is the site
preparation guide this talked about the
physical aspects needed for the
instrumentation so we talked about
electrical it talked about environmental
requirements you know is there going to
be you know buyer hazardous waste
disposal that needs to go you know into
a receptacle or you know is there stuff
that goes down the drain so the
instrument you know deposit anything
that we need to have special set ups for
and so this was really important because
this was all stuff that we for the most
part could look over and assess you know
without having to waste any time of the
actual a be process itself it
Jeff described earlier so having this
gave us a good head start on the process
in addition to those checklist we also
had a pre installation site visit by our
field service engineer we basically set
up the laboratory the way we thought it
would best work knowing that the
instruments that we had decided on
purchasing excuse me he was able to
confirm or direct us as to whether the
setup we had worked you know he's
obviously the person that's working on
the instruments he has to be able to
move around them if he's there for
service so we basically showed him this
is how we intend to set it up and he
said yay or nay which was nice because
we were able again to address these
issues long before we even took delivery
of the instrumentation in addition to
you know all the paperwork and
checklists and the site visit we had a
dedicated team at our disposal which was
really nice we had contact information
we had a good introduction meeting at
the get-go we had our field service
engineer obviously who is responsible
for coming and doing the install and
then addressing any instrument problems
we had our clinical applications
consultants that was able to help us
when we had questions about something
not looking correct of course Jeff
served as our AV project manager who was
certainly you know a great contact and
loved working with him bioinformatics
consultant super important too because
again you know even with an extensive
laboratory background this is all
relatively new you're not going to find
this information for anybody who's
certified in the laboratory you know
that's just not on our credentialing
exams at this point I certainly see it
coming forward in the future but right
now it's good to have senior leadership
or someone that you can direct questions
to to guide you through this area and
then again we also have software
assistance as Jeff mentioned instrument
protocols are included as part of the AV
package data analysis complicate excuse
me consultation and reporting templates
because the data that we are generating
and
writing to our clinicians is much more
different than anything else that we've
ever done before so we were able to get
you know sample reports very generic
just to see you know the type of numbers
and metrics that would be forwarded to
our clinicians so that was benefit
because we could get that started on the
side while we're doing the actual
validation project and I think that's
something to keep in mind is that
everything that I've mentioned these are
all little side projects you know that
are all going on simultaneously so it's
not like you can have a straight linear
process as in after you complete a you
move on to B and then C and so on and so
forth
there really are a lot of simultaneous
activities that are going on in order to
make this work successfully
so looking at additional benefits of the
consulting services again I can't stress
enough about the validation samples and
the controls that were concluded because
you know you can search the internet and
look up you know NGS controls and a
bunch of different options may come up
but how do you know which is the best
one well obviously experience is
certainly going to serve to our benefit
you know anything that's been used and
tried before other laboratories and
obviously if you're working with AV
services you know this is what they do
they work with labs every day working
with different materials and so it's
nice to have that expertise and guide us
you know to provide information and
helping us to make educated decisions
and of course that goes along with Orca
fog ml testing what are our options in
terms of confirmatory results you know
when something doesn't look quite right
or suspicious or completely new to us
you know we want to be able to say with
you know hundred percent confidence to
our clinicians yes what was reported is
what was found and true so we need to
have different ways of confirming that I
will say that personally it was great to
have the guidance of you know the papers
that are out there the Jennings papers
that's listed in the Santana one but
Jeff you know presented these to us you
know we didn't have to necessarily go
digging you know these are out there in
the literature and you can do a search
for them but to save us the time going
through he did help us uncover these and
say okay this is what the scanners and
guidelines are being published and I
will emphasize that they are guidelines
there are not a lot of strict black and
white rules at this point for sequencing
anybody following the news obviously
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid are
certainly getting involved you know with
reimbursement and what the requirements
are in order to get that reimbursement
so there's a lot of papers that are
flowing out there and I also liked that
the
the strict analytical validation that we
did was not the bare minimum
now I he mentioned earlier New York
State has a very very strict
black-and-white setting as to what they
require for their NGS validation the one
that we did was probably in the middle
which was nice so we weren't the bare
minimum the full distance in order to
meet New York state requirements and
that always makes me feel better as
somebody who's bringing in new
instrumentation and new validation and
you know new resulting for our
clinicians so this was certainly a
better benefit for us as an organization
and for our patients
you
we have a precision medicine committee
that meets I believe it's monthly and
this group is composed of our genetic
counselor our oncologists are ordering
physicians pathologists it's basically
the voice that is helping us guide our
decisions on what testing that we are
going to bring in so it was important to
us to really meet the needs of our
clientele in our selection of a
next-generation sequencing assay so we
decided to go with a solid tumor panel
as our first assay because this was a
targeted commercially available panel
that had been tried and tested there are
several papers out there including white
paper you know that discussed other
experiences with this assay and the
success that they had with them so it
made us feel good about choosing this as
our first panel and then each of the
genes in the panel has established
literature available you can do a search
on any type of publication availability
and you can find information about the
utility of each of the genes in terms of
patient's diagnosis and prognosis and
then of course you know clinical
availability that's out there we were
very cautious our AV services were very
strict m and did a great job at making
sure that you know precision and LOD and
interference you know everything was
really tied up tight making sure that
what we were providing in terms of an
end product were fantastic we had 67
patient samples validated for the FFPE
so formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue we even actually added an
addendum to this and we included FFPE
cell blocks to be available for testing
because that was another sample type
that our clinicians had expressed
interest in you know for their patients
sensitivity specificity our positive and
negative predictive values were spot-on
and strictly assessed as part of the AV
which is good and then like I said we
have a compiled list of the utility
aspect of this essay so that you know if
a clinician comes to us and asked you
know what is this particular gene for
what is this going to do for my patient
you know we can come back and say you
know here's the research that we did on
this you know in choosing this and this
is why we feel this is a good fit for
what you're requesting so thermo Fisher
did a great job and making sure that we
adhere to you know regulatory compliance
and then also met our needs in terms of
what our clinicians were asking for
you
and of course nothing goes as smoothly
as we would hope as with anything and
you know it's like next-gen sequencing
was no exception we certainly had our
complications as I mentioned our IT risk
assessment process is very cumbersome
and very timely and very frustrating
because again it's out of the
responsibility of the laboratory you
know we can bounce information back and
forth between the vendor and RIT but
ultimately you know there's nothing that
we can do outside of the bench work so
we did have some run-ins with us trying
to do the training was often difficult
because we could have the software in
the laboratory but we weren't allowed to
connect it to our internet in the
building so it was difficult to try and
do the training using the data that was
on our own instruments we actually had
to do some training with data that was
stored in a thermo Fisher cloud which
suffice and you know met our needs but
it certainly would have been easier if
we had been able to work on our own data
we had some equipment delays and by that
I don't mean the sequencing equipment
itself as I mentioned some of the
general laboratory needs in the
checklist we had you know centrifuges
that may not we thought would work but
ended up didn't working for us because
of the tube sizes for the sequencing so
we had to make some replacements
extraction is always an issue you know
we are a full-service molecular
laboratory and we have several different
ways to extract things but sequencing
was you know a new entity and the method
that we had were not going to suffice in
order to get the quality nucleic acid
that we needed for sequencing testing so
we had to make some switches on you know
small equipment and processes in order
to have an extraction process that fit
the needs of the input for next
generation sequencing we also weren't
entirely sure if we were going to do all
automated or manual testing when it
the sequencing our initial thought was
well if the instrument goes down we need
to have a manual method so when we pull
them thermal fissure that we wanted to
train for both I didn't even really bad
an eye I said okay we'll set you up you
know and they provided the training that
was needed and gave me an additional
list of supplies that are needed for the
manual method and we did we had training
manually and then we did training on
automated and then that's when we
decided that nope I don't think we need
the manual method quite that bad the
automation worked much better it fit our
needs better it reduced the personnel
time that was needed keeping costs down
and in the end we ended up having more
than one instrument so we had some
redundancy and a nice backup so if one
instrument did go down we would still
have a backup which pretty much
eliminated the need for a manual process
for sequencing and you know and the
benefits of the automation is that you
are eliminating more human error that
occurs for a manual method so that's you
know going to increase our our quality
down the line we did have a bad lot of
timers that occurred in the early stages
of our analytical validation testing and
I can't stress enough that I'm very
thankful that we had thermal Fisher you
know looking over our data and a project
manager looking at it and assessing the
issues with us because you know they're
the experts at this point you know they
are our guidance and they were able to
catch the problem in a very timely
manner and knew exactly what the next
steps were in order to fix the problem
you know replacing the lots and what
needed to be retested so that guidance
was you know certainly appreciated and
well valued because it most likely would
have taken us longer to diagnose and
troubleshoot that problem on our own so
it did set us back but I don't think it
was more than two weeks so that's you
know pretty considerable you know in
comparison to if it had been just on our
own
and then we also do to you know the
timing of it we did this during the
summer which is not always ideal because
you know there's holidays and vacations
mostly for us but you know trying to
understand that thermal Fisher's
personnel also has it is timely you know
taking time off so all of those things
did complicate our timeline but not in
such a negative way that it really put
us out the image that I have on the
right was the paperwork that we had from
thermo Fisher at the time when we were
choosing our analytical validation
package so I don't know if it quite
matches up with what Jeff showed earlier
but this is what we had when we were
considering but you know it did it was
not that far off of what it turned out
to be so overall we validated our
next-gen sequencing our first panel in a
total of eight months now keep in mind
that the a/v promised you know is closer
to 10 to 12 weeks but that really was
the time that thermo Fisher provided to
us from start to finish of the
validation samples you know we started
in March renovating space in the
laboratory and then as soon as that was
finished we were working on the pre
installation checklist and the site
evaluation and then we started the
instruments were delivered I believe in
the beginning of May and they were
installed and had their qualification
test performed by our field service
engineer in May and then training
started early in June but again we
decided to go with the manual method
first which some labs may choose not to
do that so that certainly would cut down
on the time that you spend with the
hands-on training and they include
lectures which was nice because not only
did you have the hands-on time but they
were also providing you know the theory
and the understanding which you know
that that's really important to
understand what they're doing you know
not every little instrument is a magical
black box that you just put samples in
and get results out if you need to
understand what's going on in there too
you know troubleshoot but also answer
questions from our clinicians that call
in because they want to understand
what's going on as well so we have
different lectures on workflow
methodology instrumentation software and
viral informatics and these lectures
took place scattered throughout the
training and we started with a couple
lectures and then we would go into the
lab and do hands-on wet bench and then
we would have another lecture and then
go back to the lab so that there were
you know it's very applicable I'm doing
the lecture two hands-on and then we
were able to start our validation
samples in August and we went through
August and in September and like I said
we had the I want to say a two-week
delay with the bad primers but really
you know that puts it at 12 weeks
overall because I have our you know
closeout AV meeting you know just before
Halloween so it was exciting that we
were able to do this in the time that we
did because even other instrumentation
that's not as complex as next-generation
sequencing has taken longer than eight
months so that needs to be taken into
consideration that you know any
instrument has its you know
complications and delays and stuff so we
were overall very happy with this
timeline and it was very doable and I'm
very thankful so I am glad that this was
able to work out for us and I'm very
thankful to be working with her sister
on a second validation so thank you for
inviting me to speak today
Thank You Jeffrey and Leah for your
informative presentations we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for before we start we
have a poll question we popping up on
your screen now we appreciate your
participation
you
okay let's get started our first
question is I'm new to NGS does your AP
consulting service provide data analysis
or bioinformatics consulting
you
so it does we do part of the AV packages
that we will assist you in your data
analysis during the course of your
analytical validation there will be a
couple files that we request as Lea
mentioned in our presentation we do set
up a thermal Fisher cloud site where the
data can be uploaded to the files
relatively pretty large depending on the
number of sample they're condensed down
into a single dip file but we'll walk
through you at the beginning on how you
pull those files that we'll need and
then from there we're able to access the
view VCF files and assist you through
your data analysis for that we also
there's another file that we request
from a torn suite where we do
comprehensive data analysis on how the
coverage analysis route for your DNA
portion the assay is working
great thank you okay next question can
you expand upon the benefits that your
customers have experienced during the AV
consulting process
so maybe I'll wait for that one and then
Lee I don't know if you you know want to
fill in with the second answer with that
you know I mean we've been talking with
customers and we've been working with
customers you know a lot of it is the
product management we literally put
together a schedule that will tell you
you know on you know what chip what day
what is serving what barcode to run each
sample you know just to really take the
burden of knowing what to do for your ad
you know off the labs hands also you
know with one reading the solid tumor
assays as we mentioned and providing
samples and controls we do have access
to a biorepository where we're able to
provide FFP tumor resection sections as
well as different you know contrives and
cell line controls that you'll need for
your ad and the data analysis assistance
as well
and you know I mentioned in my
presentation that we are going through
upwards of 20 runs again depending on
multiplexing the upwards of 20 runs
during a short timeframe so having
someone that's you know very comfortable
in doing this data analysis and you know
specifically on ER instrumentation is
even beneficial because we're able to
you know easily you know get this data
you can get through analyzing this data
and get it compiled and then you know
review it with each lab so while they're
learning the process well they're you
know when I li can probably speak to
this better but while they weren't still
trying to learn the process of running
the assay and get comfortable with the
everyday every day operational flow of
their next gen so you can see now say
where you in the background you know are
compiling data for them
yeah yeah if you have anything that
yes as you were saying Jeff you know it
was certainly beneficial to have a
presence in the background of you know
somebody who knows what they're doing it
you know any validation is difficult the
very first time you're really wandering
into foreign territory and you're not
quite sure if you're doing a ride and
they're trying to meet all the
regulatory so it was great to have you
know dedicated team to answer questions
for us you know to get the workflow to
get the process to get the daily feel as
to what was supposed to do what we're
supposed to do and you know
understanding the instruments better I
again the checklist were beneficial
because there are so many components to
this that happens simultaneously you
know the a/v the regulatory you know the
document writing you know having a
template provided for an SOP is great
you know because we can take what we
need from that and then fit it into our
own process
you know because each lab is
individualized on how they handle you
know procedures and policies so we were
able to have some guidance and to fit
that into our needs so yeah it was it
was really great to have a leader and
guidance you know to to get us through
this this first one and as I already
said that the second one and then after
that you know we'll be on our own
great thank you looks like we have time
for one more question what's the best
way for my company to ensure that we
have what we need to complete the ad
process
you know I would say get to know your
guidelines get a hold of the Jenny's the
Jenny's paper you know read through the
cap molecular checklist read through the
cfli guidelines and you know know what
each of these different regulatory
agencies required for expression for
analytical validation you know to do
that that is the most important thing
that you know you could do and then you
know as we mentioned in the slide where
I went over questions ask yourself those
questions and really make sure that in
addition you know to asking yourself
those questions that you have your you
know your analytical validation planned
out I mean plan in the planning is the
most important part in you know in early
days of us doing the analytical
validations and you know casseroles you
know it's if you go by the fly by the
seat of your pants method that's
typically where you'll see a validation
dry dry out you know into a year because
you're you know you're you're not
planned and you're just picking samples
out of okay maybe I'll run these snacks
maybe run these and so you don't be very
prepared for a validation and then you
know look you don't have to go with
thermo Fisher AV services to have a
validation conversation with us we
always I always tell customers and tell
our field teams that you know if a
company has a few questions about a B
I'm happy to have hop on a phone call
and go over any questions that you might
have so you know feel free to contact us
reach out and you know we can have a
conversation about you know where your
labs at you know where you want to be
and then if it's something to where we
can assist with ad service great it's
not it's just a few short questions I'm
always happy to answer
thank you again Jeffrey and Leah for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's event until next
time goodbye